soixante-dix pièces de faïence certaines
monumentales et guerre assiette ou
tableaux une collection constituée par
la famille montagnon entre 1875 et
aujourd'hui mais la fermeture de
l'ancienne manufacture du bout du monde
fin 2015 impose la cession des oeuvres
et la ville se porte acquéreur des
synthés c'est effectivement de savoir
que l'ensemble de ces pièces restera
groupe est et restera à nevers c'est
vraiment notre souhait le plus fort
c'est aussi faire en sorte que le nom
montagne on ne soit pas oubliée dans la
faïence univers l'ensemble d'une valeur
de 150 mille euros rejoindra le musée de
la faïence la ville en fournira 75 mille
la région 60 milles et le reste est
ouvert au financement participatif
l'intérêt est effectivement c'est de
trouver de nouvelles sources de
financement de partenariat pour
permettre de maintenir un niveau
d'investissement et de développer les
investissements mais c'est aussi une
façon d'associer là population au projet
porté par les collectivités
chacun peut donc participer via une
plateforme sur internet consacrés au
financement de projets culturels les
donateurs s'engagent pour une somme
entre 5 et 2500 euros en échange de
contreparties
une implication réelle pour des
copropriétaires symbolique pour que ça
soit forcément des entités ou des
collectivités locales je pense que
l'individu en tant que tel a droit aussi
à s'intéresser justement à ce qui a fait
son passé et ce qui fait aussi son sens
son devenir aussi un parce que c'est
justement protéger un terroir la ville
de nevers espère récolter les 15000
euros qui complèterait le budget la
collecte est ouverte jusqu'au 15
décembre